말을 다루시는 일을 하시는 분들 중에 유독 개그 욕심 있는 분들이 많으시더라고요.
물론 저도 예외는 아닙니다만 그만큼 웃음은 우리를 가장 행복하게 만드는 도구이자
본능적으로 해내고 싶은 가장 상위에 있는 어려운 과제인지도 모르겠습니다.
그래서 제가 오늘 조금 힘이 들어가 있는데요.
특별한 분을 모셨습니다.
30년 차 개그맨이자 20년 차 라디오 DJ
그리고 무려 4년 만에 같이 밥 먹고 싶은 아저씨 되는 법으로
따뜻한 글까지 전해주신 김태균 작가님을 모셨습니다.
어서오세요.
안녕하세요. 반갑습니다.
소리 질러.
작가님 방송 들으면서 다 같이 쿡쿡 떼고
야 너도 이러면서 통하면서 컸던 세대거든요.
그때 교실에서 혹은 직장에서 동시에 들으면서 라이브를 들으면서
특히 여자 학생들은 머리가 기니까 이어폰을 안 보이잖아.
동시에 터지는 거야. 한 교실에서.
그 에피소드 많이 왔었어.
행복했던 어떤 추억 속의 조각을 진하게 만들어주셨는데요.
아이고 감사합니다.
라디오 선배님으로서 여쭤보고 싶은 질문이 너무나 왔어요.
마음껏 하세요. 언제든지 뭐든지 얘기해드릴게요.
행복한 성덕으로서 들뜨는 방송 기대해주세요.
책에 유머 감각이 없는 사람, 유치, 괜찮다.
끝까지 밀고 나가면 언젠가는 웃게 되어 있다.
이런 글에 써주셨죠.
그래서 궁금해졌습니다.
작가님만의 그 유머를 만드는 유머 감각을 만드는 사소한 꿀팁
한 세 가지 정도 추천 가능하실까요?
좀 놀라실 수도 있고 덤덤하실 수도 있고.
저는 원래 남을 웃긴다는 얘기를 들어본 적이 없어요.
오 정말요?
제일 재밌다 혹은 제일 웃긴다 이런 얘기를 들어본 적이 없어요.
사뭇 진지하고 낯가렸던 친구예요.
내성적이기도 하고.
저는 라디오 DJ가 꿈이었던 사람이기 때문에
가수 시험도 보고 탤런트 시험도 보고
DJ가 되기 위해서 어떻게든 연예인이 되어야 하니까.
다 떨어지고 나서 마지막에 선택한 게 개그맨 시험이에요.
한 번도 써본 적 없는 3분짜리 개그 대본을 혼자 쓴 거예요.
조용히 가족들한테도 얘기 안 하고 아무도 모르고
저는 몰래 혼자 써서 혼자 시험을 봤는데 그게 된 거야.
우와.
그래서 내가 개그맨이 됐다는 거 자체가 주위에 진짜 떠들썩였어요.
쟤가 왜 개그맨이 돼?
재밌다고 생각해 본 적이 한 번도 없는 애인데
우리 엄마도 놀라고 친구도 놀라고 다 놀라서
그때부터 되게 개그맨 생활이 시작된 거예요.
어? 저렇게 하면 재밌네 하는 거를 보고
약간 빨아들이는 능력이 꽤 남들보다 빨랐던 것 같아요.
그래서 나름 터득한 방법들이 있어요.
그래서 사람들을 웃기고 싶다고 해서 흔히 인터넷이나 온라인에 올라 있는
흔히 인터넷이나 온라인에 올라 있는
개그라든가 아재개그라든가 개인기라든가 이런 걸 연습해서
기술적으로 장착하고 다닌다고 해서
그게 유머러스한 게 아니라는 거예요.
제발 그딴 짓 하지 말라는 거예요.
절대로 하지 말라는 거예요.
물론 소스로 이용될 수는 있는데 그게 중요한 게 아니고
제일 중요한 건 생긴 대로 살면 유머러스할 수 있다.
그게 무슨 얘기냐.
얼굴 못생기고 그냥 개성 있는 얼굴이 아니라
눈이 두 개잖아요.
코구멍도 두 개가 있고
귓구멍도 두 개가 있어요.
입은 하나죠.
보기를 많이 보고
듣기도 하고
듣기도 많이 듣고
의심도 많이 해보고
냄새도 많이 맡고
약간 말은 적게 하는 거예요.
그 얘기는 뭐냐
남 얘기를 많이 들어야지 웃길 수 있어요.
때시가 아마 좀 딴 얘기로 빠지거나
까먹었을 때쯤에서
그걸 소재삼아 툭 던지는 거예요.
그러면 둘만의 공감대가 생기면서
마음이 확 열려요.
뭐 하나가 터졌어.
그걸 기억해야 돼요.
똑똑해야 돼요. 나름.
기억력이 좋아야 돼요.
어 맞아요.
딱 해놓고 어 저게 재밌었네.
그러다가 사람들 또 자기들 얘기하느라고 바쁘거나
시간이 흘러지는 거예요.
그리고 까먹을 때쯤
아까 웃겼던 걸 한 번 더 터뜨려요.
반복이라고 얘기합니다.
이게 되게 아주 하이 스킬이에요.
그만큼 노력이 필요하고
귀 기울여 남의 얘기를 들어야지
그런 기회가 온다는 거예요.
준비한 건 하는 게 아니라
대화 중에서 얘기를 탁 던지는 거예요.
은근히 웃기는 사람은 될 수 있을 것 같아요.
예.
쉽지 않아요.
쉽지 않은데 된다?
근데 뭐 스킬이 또 하나 있어.
자기가 얘기하고
자기가 먼저 웃는 거 되게 꼴 보기 싫잖아요.
근데 남이야.
남이 한 얘기에 먼저 웃어주잖아.
어? 저 자식이 내가 한 얘기에 웃어주네.
그러면서 그것부터 마음을 열기 시작해요.
남이 한 얘기에 먼저 웃어주세요.
그게 진짜 좋은 스킬이야.
아 개그도 결국 교감이군요.
아 완전.
대화랑 비슷한 점이 굉장히 많습니다.
야 이거는 오늘 다 얘기해 줘야
이것만 갖고도 한 시간 이상 할 것 같아.
특강을 저희가 또 만들어봐야겠습니다.
그런데 또 반대로도 궁금해졌어요.
이렇게 베테랑 작가님을 웃기게 하는 말도 있으셨어요.
나를 요즘 웃기게 하는 건
뭐 우리 가족들이죠.
너무 귀여운 모습.
우리 와이프가 이렇게 막 시끄러워서 표현도 잘 못하거든요.
근데 이제 제가 퇴근하고 집에
이제 딱 집에 돌아왔을 때
마스크 벤처럼
샤아아아아아
왓쌔!
이렇게 슥 미끄러지면서
샤아아아아아아아
왜 하는 건지 모르겠는데
내가 좋아하니까 하겠지 아무래도.
리액션이 있으니까.
내가 딱 들어
뭐하는 짓이야?
귀 멀은 거야 지금!
이렇게 하면 안 할 거 아니야.
근데 그래도 웃길 것 같아요.
어머.
그 반응 보려고 또 하고 싶을 것 같아요.
어 그러니까.
아 그게 너무 웃기고.
와이프가 재밌어요.
그리고 요즘 우리 아들이 스무 살이 됐는데
머리를 계속 길르고 있어요.
오오.
혹시 락 음악이나 이런 쪽이 좀
아냐 그게 아니고
그냥 한 번은 길러봐야 되겠다고 생각해요.
더봉 머리 총각이 맨날
으아아아 하고 돌아다니니까
정리 안 되는 막
이렇게 더봉 머리 총각이 이렇게
돌아다니는 것도 너무 웃기고
신혼이 넘어가면서
길거리에
피어난 들꽃이라든가
꽃들이 그거 그렇게 웃음 짓게 해줘요.
그니까 때마다 피어나는 꽃들이 다르잖아요.
그런 제철에 피어나는 꽃들이
말을 걸어주고
이렇게 돌아다니고
가끔 한 번씩 불어주는 바람이 딱 이렇게 있으면
그래도 이렇게 웃게 돼요.
예전에는 절대로 그것 때문에 웃지 않았던 것들이
나에게 많은 웃음을 줘요.
그래서 너무 큰 위로가 돼요.
선배님의 말씀에서 어떻게 보면
인생에 좀 여유가 느껴지거든요.
좀 부럽기도 합니다.
선배님처럼 빨리 여유를 찾고 싶은
치열하게 살고 있는 저뿐만 아니라
우리 히리텔도 계실 것 같거든요.
근데 이것들이 왜 이렇게 생기냐면
어차피 겪어내야 되는 여러 가지 일들이 있어요.
그걸 겪어내고 나면 결국엔 내가 중요하구나.
내가 마음이 단단하고 어쩔 때는 유연하고
몽글몽글해져야지 잘 버텨나갈 수 있구나
라는 것을 알게 되는 순간
이 강직되어 있던 강박 같은 게 사라진 거죠.
경직이 돼있으면 이렇게 힘을 꽉 주고
어떻게든 버텨야 돼 이게 아니라
그냥 유연한 거예요.
치건하듯이 그렇게 되는 것 같아요.
결국에는 다 유연, 힘 빼기의 기술.
근데 중요한 건
겪어야 돼요.
겪지 않고선 그런 상황이 되고 싶다고 하는 건 욕심이에요.
어떻게 보면 경험이 주는 선물이네요.
경험을 줘야 돼요.
그래서 이번에 쓰게 된 책도
조금 더 힘들게 열심히 살아내고 있는
지금의 우리 후배님들, 젊은 친구들한테
유연해졌으면 좋겠다는 생각으로
한번 안아주고 싶어서 쓴 글이기 때문에
그래서인지 책을 읽고 나서 기분이 너무 좋았어요.
다행이네요.
되게 술 한 잔 선배님하고 하면서
위로를 크게 받은 느낌이 들었거든요.
우리 혜리들도 한번
꼭 한번 읽어보셨으면 좋겠습니다.
그러면 아까 라디오 얘기를 잠깐 하셨는데요.
어떤 사연이나 청취자나 그런 분들 중에
기억에 남으시는 분이 있는지가 궁금해요.
기억에 남는 사람이 너무 많고요.
방청을 오셨던 분들이 몇 명 계신데
보자마자 저 보면서 우는 분들이 꽤 있어요.
자기가 죽고 싶을 정도로 힘들게 우울하게 살아왔는데
책임진 방송을 듣고 희망을 가지고
그 우울감에서 벗어났어요.
그래서 너무 감사해서 보자마자 눈물이 난다고
한번 안아보면 안 돼요.
그래서 한 번 안아보면 안 돼요. 한 번 안아보면 안 돼요.
그래서 한 번 안아보면 안 돼요.
심지어는 어떤 정신과, 신경정신과 의사분이
처방으로 컬투쇼를 들어보라고 얘기를 해주신 분이 계시대요.
근데 그거 듣고 나서 너무 좋아졌다면서
또 이렇게 안아달라고 하시는 분도 계시고
그런 분들이 진짜 많으세요.
컬투쇼라는 라디오 방송이
대한민국에 어디 아프시고
수술 후 회복하시는 분들한테
아주 커다란 회복력을 주는 친구예요.
오늘 라디오 방청 오신 분이
저 라세카우, 라세카우.
눈 감고 있는 동안 진짜
이거 없었으면 어떡할 뻔했어요 진짜
그렇게 얘기하시는 분들 진짜 많고
임신하신 분들이 태교로 진짜 많이 들으세요.
그리고 임산부들이 방청객으로 진짜 많이 오세요.
웃음으로 청취자들을 치유를 하시다 보면
또 작가님은 언제 웃으실까
가끔 작가님께도 마음의 그늘이 생기실 순간들도 있을 텐데
그럴 때 주로 어떤 식으로 극복을 하시는 편인지도 궁금합니다.
사실 어머니가 투병하실 때가 제일 힘들었고
돌아가시고 나서 어머니가
너는 행복해야 한다.
엄마는 그러지 못했어.
그러니까 네가 좋아하는 거 찾아서 즐기면서 살아라.
엄마는 그러지 못했으니까.
그래서 그 이후에 어머님이 이제
하늘나라로 돌아가시고 나서
행복에 되게 집중하게 됐어요.
여기도 행복에 관한 얘기가 있어요.
행복에 관한 정의가 있어요.
행복이란 내가 좋아하고 하고 싶었던 것을 찾아서
즐기면서 집중되는 지금 이 순간의 느낌이지.
지금 이 순간에만 느낄 수 있는 감정이야.
그런데 사람들이 그걸 찾지 못해.
아유 내 주제에 뭐.
내가 뭘 좋아하는 거야.
가족들 먼저 챙기고. 애들이나 가족들을 행복하게 하려면 내가 먼저 행복해야 돼.
내가 좋아하는 걸 즐기는 거야. 그래서 뭐 글도 쓰기도 하고 재즈 음악을 듣기도 하고
예쁜 동생들 밥 사주기도 하고. 그렇게 보면 하루가 바빠요. 그리고 집에 딱 들어가면 와이프가 촥!
촥! 나타난다는 거야. 그럼 또 옆에서 더박머리가 막 지나가고.
정말 행복하신다는 게 다 느껴져요. 에너지로, 말씀으로, 표정으로요.
혜인 씨도 혜인 씨 나름의 행복을 찾고 있잖아요.
찾고 있습니다. 열심히.
아니 근데 우리의 인생은 죽을 때까지 행복을 찾는 거예요.
왜냐면 때마다 다른 행복들이 있기 때문에.
맞아요. 그 행복을 지금 포커스해서 더 열심히 찾아봐야겠습니다.
찾으세요.
네. 그러겠습니다.
책은 얘기로 살짝 넘어가 볼게요.
인생에서 제일 위험한 말을 책에 베스트 3로 꼽아주셨거든요.
이번 한 번만, 한 번쯤은 어때?
진짜 이번이 마지막? 이거 세 가지를 꼽으셨더라고요.
이게 제일 아슬아슬할 때 하는 말이에요.
어렸을 때도 제일 많이 하는 말이에요.
어른들 중에도 이걸 하고 있는 사람들이 있죠. 그런 사람들이 아내는 애인 거야.
나 한 번 한다고 세상이 뭐 알겠어? 아주 무책임한 말 중에 하나거든요.
당신의 인생의 족쇄를 채운단 말이에요.
질질 끌려 나가게 되고 이런 철퇴 같은 걸 끌고 다니게 만들어질 수도 있어요.
안녕하세요라는 프로그램을 하다가 느낀 것 중에 제일 많이 나오는, 제일 싫어하는 말 중에 하나가
가족이니까.
이게 정말 거지같은 무책임한 말이에요.
맞아요. 가족이라는 이름의 폭력이라는 생각이 들어요.
가까이 있지만 더 멀리 있는 게 가족일 수 있어요.
언제든지 또 멀어질 수도 있잖아요.
그러니까.
말에서 이미 그 사람의 어떤 모습이 많이 드러나 있는 경우가 많아요.
시선을 못 맞추는 사람이 있어요.
인증 보고 얘기하는 사람이 있고 여기 미간 보고 얘기하는 사람이 있어요.
맞아요.
그것도 훈련인 것 같아요.
눈을 좀 보다 보면 그 사람이 진심이 좀 많이 느껴지고 하다 보니까
그 사람을 보러 또 좀 가시셨으면 좋겠다.
PD들 들으셨죠? 아이콘도 굉장히 중요합니다.
중요합니다.
예전에 PD로서 연출을 할 때 어떤 아이돌분의 덕후가 된 적이 있어요.
촬영하고 팬이 된 거죠.
그분이 연출하는 연출자인 저를 너무 예쁜 표정으로 보는데
같은 여잔데 사랑에 빠질 것 같은 거예요.
약간 플러팅 눈빛이었어요.
있어요. 있어요.
눈빛이 굉장히 크다는 걸 저도 느꼈습니다.
광선이 나가요.
이번에는 좀 특징 중에 부정적인 얘기를 살짝 넘어가 보려고 하는데요.
네네. 좋아요.
이걸 또 써주셨더라고요.
그럼에도 살면서 좀 멀리해야 되는 사람들에 대한 이야기 말이죠.
질색하는 사람 중에 한 사람이 자기가 말하는 거를 지키지 않는 사람.
말과 행동이 다른 사람이 있어요.
내가 다음에 해. 이렇게 해줄게.
그럼 해줘야 되잖아.
안 하죠.
안 하는 거야.
우리 언제 밥 먹자 이거 너무 많이 하잖아요.
예전에 우리 이용열 선배님께서 그런 적이 있어요.
이거를 너무 싫어하셔서 도시락을 허리에 차고 댕겨요.
지금 여기서 좀 먹어.
한 숟갈 떠 너도.
대단하시네요.
그런 말씀을 하신 적이 있어요.
빈말을 안 하는 거예요.
인정하지 않는 사람 너무 싫어요.
배알이 꼴려서 상대방이 잘하는 걸 인정 안 하는 사람들이 있어요.
있죠.
다 자기 공으로 가져가기도 하잖아요.
진심으로 인정해주고 축하해주고 잘된 걸 남들이.
그러면서 자기가 같이 동반상승 되는 걸 몰라요.
그리고 내가 잘못한 것을 고스란히 솔직하게 인정하는.
이것도 꼽아주셨어요. 책에.
당연한 듯 얻어먹기만 하는 거짓말.
그게 꼭 얻어먹는 것뿐만이 아니라 그런 이상한 격없는 행동들.
같이 있을 때 해서는 안 되는 행동들을 서슴없이 하는 친구들이 있어요.
뭐 대 친구 대.
아니 친구는 더 잘해줘야지.
예의 없는 사람들.
식당에 있다고 해서 서빙하는 어른을 막대하는 친구들.
주위에서 기름 넣는데 어른인데 막대하는 친구들.
맞아요.
그건 고쳤을 수 없어요. 끊어내야 돼요.
그런데 그런 행동 하나에서 사소한 것만 봐도 사람이 보이잖아요.
보이죠. 보이죠.
이렇게 손절 얘기를 했으니까 반대로.
반대로.
조금 곁에 두었을 때 되게 좋았던.
저도 지금 생각난 사람이 몇 명 이렇게 지나가는데.
나이가 아주 지긋하신 형님도 있고.
동생 뻘 내는 친구도 있고.
어떤 피해나 이런 걸 절대 끼치지 않는 사람들이 대부분이고.
배려가 몸에 배어있어요.
그리고 상대방의 기분을 살피고.
그런 사람들은 그냥 고맙고 되게 따뜻해져요.
옆에 같이 있으면.
어떻게 보면 나보다 좀 남을 생각해 보려고 하는.
그렇죠.
배려심이.
이타적인 생각이 있는 사람들.
그렇죠.
착하다는 말이 그런 분들인 것 같아요.
착하다는 말이 어떻게 보면 어린 친구들이나 이런 사람들이 볼 때.
별로 할 말이 없고 매력이 없으니까.
욕하는 건가?
착한 것은 이타적인 거더라고요.
바보 같은 게 아니에요.
생각보다 은근히 소리 없이 강한 게 착한 게 아닌가 싶어요.
맞아요.
마지막으로 인간관계 소통에 관심이 많으신 분들.
인간관계 소통에 관심이 많은 우리 2030히리뜨께 못다한 말씀이 있다면 한 말씀 부탁드립니다.
책을 같이 밥 먹고 싶으면 하실 때는 뭘 쓴 이유가.
사실은 아들이 읽었으면 좋겠어서 쓴 책이에요.
이게 무슨 어떻게 삶을 살아가는 길라잡이가 아니에요.
그냥 먼저 삶을 살아본 아빠 같은.
삼촌 같은 형 같은 사람이 조금이라도 좀 도움이 됐으면 좋겠다라고 해서.
약간 안아주고 싶고 다독이를 주고 싶어서 쓴 글이에요.
이렇게 되니까 이렇게 피해 가십시오라는 게 아니라.
맞서야 된다는 얘기를 해드리고 싶어요.
말도 안 되는 상황이 나한테 펼쳐지더라도 어차피 나한테 오는 일이면 아주 당당하게 맞서서 유연하게 그걸 해결할 필요가 있어요.
그게 유연하지 못하더라도 그래도 한 번 그렇게 맞서 보고 나면 아주 유연해져요.
돌아가지 말고 늘 직면하시길 바랍니다.
와 박수로.
마지막에 감동적인 말씀까지 우리 히리뜨 오늘 빼놓을 말이 별로 없네요.
또 우리 김태균 작가님 보내드리면서 저희 인사드리겠습니다.
오늘도 채널 고정해주신 히리.
내일도 즐겁게만 걸으세요.
안녕.